en el bosque a 10 km de butch a la
tierra recién excavada indica un
descubrimiento siniestro
la prensa mundial ha sido convocada al
desentierro de otra fosa común
son los cuerpos de siete hombres
descubiertos cuando los combatientes
voluntarios que patrullaban vieron dedos
que sobresalían del suelo
después de ser exhumados los cuerpos
serán examinados por los equipos
forenses que investigan los crímenes de
guerra
el jefe de policía de kiev apunta que
los primeros indicios señalan que las
víctimas fueron ejecutadas de un tiro en
la cabeza por las tropas rusas esta
primavera
les dispararon en las rodillas lo que
nos indica que fueron torturados les
ataron las manos a la espalda con cinta
adhesiva lo que indica que estas
personas fueron retenidas durante
bastante tiempo y que intentaron sacarle
zhang una información normal hasta ahora
se han descubierto más de 1.300
cadáveres en la región de kiev cientos
de personas siguen desaparecidas ya que
las búsquedas se ralentizan por las
minas terrestres en la zona
creo que se necesitarán varios años para
retirar todos los cadáveres de la región
de kiev porque el enemigo se ensaña
secuestrando incluso civiles solitarios
sobre los que no tenemos ninguna
información al pro ya que esta donación
viene ya con armas las tropas rusas
acamparon en estos bosques cuando
intentaban tomar la capital y ahora un
enterrador local siguió trabajando un
tiempo durante la ocupación rusa cuando
aparecían cada vez en las calles alguien
nos llamaba cuando la gente veía un
cadáver todos los lugareños nos conocían
decían han matado a alguien lo traeremos
aquí por favor vengan a enterrarlo así
que si podíamos cogíamos un ataúd
recogíamos el cuerpo y lo enterramos en
el cementerio dos meses después de la
retirada de los rusos los bosques de los
alrededores de kiev siguen siendo
testigos de la brutalidad y los horrores
de la guerra siguen saliendo a la luz